[Music]
spring in John Smoltz John do you like a
Fletch what's that do you watch the
movie Fletch with oh yeah oh yeah is it
good yeah oh yeah that was look you know
the only reason why wound Hamby on I
mean if Dumb and Dumber is your favorite
movie which it is you know Fletch is
going to fall in that category to give
me your favorite comedy John
oh it's dumb and Dumberer I watch that
again you can it doesn't matter where it
is in the movie you can watch it and
it's great it's like stepbrothers you
can do that you just watch it and you
continue to watch it that's exactly
right
and I it never gets old but you can't
once you have a movie like that you
can't do that's evil you know I know I
know I know and we do it we did it to
Caddyshack we do it to a few of these
and you just can't do them so have you
been in a movie yeah I was at 7 hours
had my own trailer the movie the
change-up and then I went to the actual
theater to watch it only to find out it
and make it good I delivered my line
flawlessly I looked at it over and over
I cross-checked it analytically it was
driven perfectly it just didn't make the
final cut they didn't tell you before
you got to the movie theater no oh no
that's tough but I went to a late movie
so there was a many people there who was
in the change up with you Ryan Reynolds
Olivia Wilde oh my gosh I was supposed
to be well I was the Atlanta Braves
pitching coach they were filming the
scene there where they're at the stadium
watching the game and like I said I mean
I I think it's a record that I only had
to do the line a couple times I did it
so well but obviously not well enough
didn't make the cut who was
better-looking Ryan Reynolds or Olivia
Wilde both fine-looking human being okay
I say it was Bull Durham realistic there
were parts but no no it's not realistic
but there was you know you take look I'm
one of these guys I cannot
watch a sports movie unless it's like a
slapstick comedy but any anybody that
tries to do a sports movie and bypasses
the most obvious stuff that I guess 80%
of the people won't pick up I'm sitting
there picking it apart I just it's a bad
habit but unless it's like a goof like
slap shot or something I I I think it's
hard for me to watch a sports movie
right give me what bothered you in most
available during oh I don't know if
anything Bobby because that was more of
a of a spoof but I think the thing that
you know I don't know maybe the
portrayed life of a baseball player that
might fall in that category is less than
5% you didn't have a Susan Sarandon
waiting for you in the minor leagues now
no no but you know I did have moments
where I could have hit the bull my first
pitch in pro ball hits the the guy holds
them it was going to hit the guy and he
got out of the way and hit it any and it
hit the bat and behind me huh there's my
first strike this is all day so you
threw behind him accidentally and it hit
the bat I don't yeah actually I was so
nervous instructional league and I was
nervous and you know right out of high
school and he steps up there and I'm
like all right no big deal and I throw
it and I'm like oh my gosh and it he
ducked and it hit the bat knowing all
right great one here we go
walk me through when did you learn bean
ball etiquette when yeah you know it's
interesting how we've talked about how
much the game has changed he could do 40
shows on it but that you just you were
told by veteran players or at least like
I was told things that there's nothing
to do with the game how to take care of
the clubhouse guys what to do here you
know you were told things to kind of
respect the way players had kind of you
know honor don't pave the way or
whatever and and then you would have
some veteran guys on your team that
especially a veteran pitcher if you had
any questions this is how you do this so
that's how you do the hat and you know
the number one
thing for me has always been never near
a guy's shoulder heads ever ever I mean
that's just like that would be the
number one thing you don't do and the
other thing they don't remember being
told if the manager tells you to do
something you better know how to do it
you better get it right the first time
and never really had any issues with
that or misgivings of like confusion
because it can it can despite what you
you know the obvious of what it could do
to a person it can mess up your team and
your team chemistry if things are
handled improperly but do you think the
Giants handled it improperly with the
Strickland the reaction from Buster
Posey the fact that he did this holding
a grudge from 2014 you know again that's
the thing that's amazing to me when you
sit back everybody can look at things a
different way and everyone can see it a
different way right and internally you
know things are discussed it's never
going to come out no one's ever going to
say hey this is this is what happened
here and I and I think look the first
thing I'm going to say he whether you
agree with it or not he hit him in the
right spot right I mean it we've had
uglier situations that nobody talks
about we've had guys getting thrown
behind their head that I lose my mind on
that never gets any bigger publicity
because the batter decided not to charge
the mind but you know the Machado
situation yeah that whole thing played
out that was that was that's where you
get to the point where the it never ends
or it doesn't seem like there's an
ending point I've always struggled with
if you're better off to strike first
because then then what I mean to me the
game has has gone off the rails in a lot
of different ways and one of the ways
it's gone off the rails as guys are
ill-prepared to do whether you like it
or not pitch inside or take care of
business whatever that means are
translated that's where it gets a little
bit fuzzy for me when you throw them all
up near a guy's head I'm sorry it better
have slipped and you know the difference
between when a pitch
slip in a curveball versus you know
trying to try to hurt somebody or at
least not know how to do it do you
respect Harper for charging the mound
was that the right thing to do you know
it's funny because yeah but here's the
thing about the game the recourses of
the American League versus two
nationally meaning the American League
guys never back writing you see it
happened a lot more in American league
pitchers who have to stand on the mound
and stand in the plate are going to feel
differently about a scenario unless your
reliever and you don't get to hit a lot
but I mean the fact that that he decided
in that moment to do it well that's
that's that's like people acting as if
they never got mad at somebody cutting
them off on the highway and they've
always been patient and thinking you
know it happens and that's the thing the
emotion happens but are you more apt to
throw in heartburn noun no see where I
think is crazy is when you start
deciding I need to get one up on your
team I need to you hit two my guys like
we need to hit three or you hit one
we're going to pick up that's where the
game loses its whether you want to call
it coloring outside the lines or not
that's what that's up to somebody else's
own interpretation I really believe that
most managers always have a good
heartbeat of what's going on and players
make bad decisions based on emotion and
they think they're doing something on
the benefit of their team and the
reality they're only putting other
people in harm's way there's that's
where you get into your first question
what's the right way in the wrong way
this thing's over I mean that you sure
Harper ended oh yeah I mean I would
think that that that would be something
where you know that's a long time two
years I get it everyone's going to try
to focus on that I think the biggest
thing is you know whether you're trying
to bury a ball in or if it smells and
looks like he exacted his revenge and
both sides uh I'm not saying that's
right wrong or different but I think
it's it's over I don't think that's
going to be I think there'll be a lot of
respect on both part parties and
Strickland is going to try
to get him out the rest of his career
and Harper's going to try to hit four
more home runs he's John Smoltz Major
League Baseball Network analyst you can
watch John on MLB tonight airs live
seven days a week
MLB Network features Yankees Blue Jays
tomorrow at 7:00 Eastern
I run day I had something for you by the
way and and I and I and it just wasn't
in the cards I saw yeah it seems like
two months ago at the at the Emmys yeah
and my passion bucket that was gonna be
part of the speed yeah yeah I was it was
going to be I know you're going to tear
up I saw you in the role I didn't get a
chance come over and see you in but I
had it ahead unfortunately never got to
the stage to be able to do that for you
alright well I appreciate that do you uh
do you remember somebody that you went
after did you ever hold a grudge and he
hit somebody no I never hit somebody
because they couldn't get him out if
that was the case Tony Gwynn a little
bit I did have a couple of a couple
couple pot points where I was told to
brush a guy back did you ever hit
somebody on purpose
yes who'd you hit um well I'm livery let
me retract that I wanted to throw the
ball inside unfortunately Cangelosi
stood two inches it was unfair it wasn't
going after him it wasn't any reflection
around him I didn't even pick up my head
after the Grand Slam this was a Ryan
Thompson hit the grand slam off of me
and okay Angelo C was next he was next
and and as the story goes unfortunately
I I'm just I'm not seeing real well
right now I'm not happy and I said you
know what I'm throwing the next pitch
inside and I did and if you look at it
it was hell he was two inches from the
play to hit him he charged him out so
after the brawl Bobby Bonilla had the
greatest line ever
because Ryan Klesko was playing right
field and he made three errors on two
plays which got to the bases loaded
which got to the o2 slider that I pong
and the Brian Thompson hit a home run
and took forever to get around the bases
Bobby Bonilla said you should hit Klesko
he's the guy that got you
and I did think that was pretty funny
but I got an eight-game suspension and
the largest given out at any point in
baseball and the rash of like that was
probably the seventh there was a rash of
brawls that were happening and Danno
president said that's enough and you
know it I got I got an eight-game
suspension but we hit the fewest guys I
think in the history of the game with
the amount of innings that I that I
pitch I it's got to be less than 17 or
16 or someone that category fine I
didn't check on that check on that what
it's a stance Inc that Smoltz he thinks
he hit fewer batters per innings than
anybody in the history of the game
mady's didn't hate anybody right what
that Maddux didn't hit anybody he would
hit guys with a two seamer that was all
just ran Valen yeah yeah yeah Paulie I
have John at 57 hit by pitch in 21
seasons yesterday we'll check on the
ratio John you said 17 no no no no I'm
saying I'm saying that I guess when you
think about the amount of innings to the
guys that I hit yeah that's a lot that's
one every six when every whatever the
racial comes to how many Hall of Famers
did you hit I don't know but I do have
this in 1991 and 92 John led the majors
in wild pitches that's correct
that's the Bull Durham yes that's I have
a record in the all-star game in
Baltimore I have three wild pitches in
one inning don't you love it when you
come on we never celebrate your career
it's always hey I know and I thought
you're going to talk about since I
turned 50 I'm trying for the senior
qualifier coming up in a week but I I
knew this would you know that's later
we'll talk about that one I mean you
know how about yeah you qualifying and
we'll talk about all right good con you
poor thing you've had nothing go right
in your life man I hope something
happens good to you all right
wrong you can see John on MLB tonight
displaying this type of sense of humor
seven days a week plus Yankees Blue Jays
tomorrow at 7:00 Eastern on MLB Network
John it's great to talk
again all right there all right he just
turned 50 on May 15th John Smoltz the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience